So the first step of Tomasulo's algorithm that we will consider is issue.
So what happens during issue? We take the next instruction in program order
from the instruction queue. This has to be done in program order for
register renaming to work correctly. We then need to determine where the inputs
of the instructions are going to come from. Are they already in the register
file or are they going to be produced by some of the instructions that still
hasn't broadcast its result? And if we need to wait for instruction, which one?
So there will be some sort of RAT table there. We're then going to get a free or
available reservation station of the correct kind.
Note that there are some reservation stations that are for the adder,
some of them are for the multiplier. So if this is an add instruction,
then we really need to find a available reservation station in front of
the other. If all of the reservation stations are busy at this point,
meaning they're already used by some other instructions and they're, those
instructions haven't left yet, then we simply don't issue anything this cycle.
And in Tomasulo's algorithm, they were issuing one instruction at a time, so,
so they, they would just issue one instruction per cycle.
We would put the instruction in the reservation station then.
And we will tag the destination register of the instruction so
that the result, when it's produced, goes there and also so
that instructions that want that register in the future will know which
instruction is going to produce this value if it has already not been produced.